[Music]
wing white
we fight for time time in fort
took one and for months we are in the mood and
ability to act
sing normally  Today we have
[Music]
Evita Perón and she is squeezing things
Caracas with air and Apatzingán tying
churches to people I
needed Yokohama a chop Natasha's house
or go to your comment
mom I if there is no activity there is no iron in
trying to avoid biscayne inter son
unit take  and more dear
writings allow or not
everything has a price
[Music]
we are offering you go present to
have everything kill your insides
costs urki start swimming
freedom protection without getting
a tactic that has a connotation of
simon we avoid this cause of  this match
is not a formality but he has said that I
put a text here it is to try and
really play I do not eat and he has another date with
haiti
and machos in a little bit
p  sponsored and habitat this is television
el malabar we need that so
serene contest with some data to manage
etc sometimes they are seen in quarries and
defamation and motions we finish almost
none
since today it is more and it is a part of
people who want to call the channel
[Music]
with each vote no fridge is
done
we are from here a visual like that today
is the one that takes back the hotel and nothing
even touched the polite american
[Music]
her mouth system is
the truth is that don omar and it's that no
that's not
[Music]  ]
are enormous
already in May 2008
[Music]
the mainstream
in the morgue from his country tree
yes yes
in the analysis
[Music]
of fruits
the power
[Music]
in him
[Music  ]
[Applause]
The construction of a giant tea bar
takes approximately six
months,
weighing almost 12 quintals in structure alone.
We expect around 130,000
people to visit us throughout the year.
day and these visitors come from all
over the world and for which they
come to visit and want to know the
majestic barrels since it is a Guatemalan bread
well my name is Julio Roberto
I need I have dedicated myself to making kites
for 24 years
[Music]
[  Applause]
with salvation
the celebration of the
kite festival here in your hand
has been carried out for many years, perhaps
300 years now, and in it there is an
oral history where it says that on
November 2
precisely God is told that he gave
permission to  all the spirits that came down
to earth to visit their relatives
then, together with the good
spirits, they also say that the
bad spirits came down and came to
bother those who rested in the cemeteries
6 on facebook karma people
describe as the body
for  the making of a kite
precisely everything is done or started in the
family so the grandparents the parents
the uncles are the ones who  they instill in one
to get involved in making or designing a
kite
[Music]
so all the emotion that one
puts in there makes on November 1,
19, his kite jump and
scream with emotion to see that his
kite has risen
[Applause  ]
the yipao parade was born more than
25 years ago
what was sought was how to reflect
our identity, our idiosyncrasy
and what we
peasants do for a living my family does it for the
guy's parade he does it out of passion it is
something very wasteful and if not  Had
there been passion, we wouldn't be here
[Music]
[Applause]
My name is Adriana Patricia.
For more than 20 years, my families have been
participating in
the hip
hop parade contest. The yipao parade is a
cultural event where it
is celebrated  acknowledgment of the hit that is the one that
has led to the development of our
region
[Music]
initially the economy and transportation
was done on the back of a mule because there were
no roads for its  state
then we adopted the gym
[Music]
so as our department from a
coffee vocation my family think
it is good to reflect in a jeep even what
is the culture of coffee so my car
is decked out with everything that is used
on the coffee farm to get to
processing a coffee bean
takes about two
days, also organizing and assembling
the vehicle, it is assembled little by little
and each little thing is tied up
carefully because each little thing tells
a story
the yipao parade breaks down into
various categories and we participate in
several categories there is the
agricultural cargo category my husband also competes
in that
arts and crafts category also because we use
that it is my category
the yipao contest the award is
money and almost every year he won
first place for gym number one
adriana here
[  Music]
[Applause]
apart from being a cultural manifestation, it
is something familiar behind each step there is
a family  lia and behind each family there is
a story
[Music]
so the contestants each year are almost
always the same but as
new generations come behind
us it grows more because it is like the
legacy we leave in each of
our loved ones
[Music]
[Applause  ]
dyn
for gaspart
cows